jamie foxx and daughter corrine are
showing off their father-daughter bond
it's another e.t exclusive
so listen karen father's day is right
around the corner so what is your
favorite
part of daddy daughter relationship
you put so much work into getting to
know you know me
and annelise and you know you took me to
jones brothers concerts you took me to
taylor swift concerts
me and taylor swift i loved every minute
this father-daughter duo is super close
they produce their sitcom
dad stop embarrassing me and they've got
their game show together
beat shazam ladies and gentlemen
has been with the fox family for years
watch a clip from an old interview
with us i i'm actually kind of nervous
what have you learned from this whole
process and watching your dad go through
all these wonderful
award shows that takes a lot of hard
work
to get where my dad is right now um
[Music]
i'm so grateful that i was there i
didn't really understand
yeah because you know what the magnitude
of what that was gonna be
you didn't because me and your mother
didn't want you to be
immersed in that you know i just kind of
wanted you to just grow up
just be a kid maybe you thought your dad
wasn't doing nothing
i always tell you man you can soar to
the highest height because you got it
it's inside of you and it's great to be
able to sit back and watch that unfold